[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielleicht handelt es sich um eine
banale Weisheit aber wahr ist sie
trotzdem an die Spitze zu kommen ist das
eine dort zu bleiben eine ganz andere
Sache und was so sehr beim Sport und in
der Wirtschaft gilt passt auch aufs
Militär denn auch dort findet ein
Wettbewerb statt der Wettbewerb um die
schlagkräftigste Truppe wie wichtig das
für ein Land sein kann sehen wir derzeit
bei jedem Blick in die Nachrichten und
wie im Sport ist es auch beim
militärischen Wettstreit alle jagen den
Favoriten diejenigen der ganz oben steht
in diesem Fall sind das die USA
unbestritten steht dieses Land an der
Spitze in Sachen military power aber an
dieser Spitze hat es eben mit ganz
eigenen speziellen Herausforderungen zu
kämpfen und eines könnt ihr mir glauben
diese Herausforderungen bereiten den
militärstrategien was schenken gerade
gewaltige Kopfschmerzen denn es steht
folgende Frage im Raum inwieweit können
die USA ihre militärische Vorherrschaft
überhaupt aufrecht erhalten hat der
Krieg in der Ukraine vielleicht
ernsthafte Probleme im US-Militär
offenbart einige dieser Probleme haben
wir bereits in einem früheren Video auf
visual Politik angesprochen ich werde es
euch verlinken seht es euch unbedingt an
falls ihr es verpasst haben solltet und
denkt bitte daran auch unseren Kanal zu
abonnieren unbedingt mit Glöckchen denn
dann werdet ihr keines unserer
interessanten Videos mehr verpassen
schließlich sind all diese Fragen im
aktuellen geopolitischen Kontext
wichtiger denn je schaut euch nur an was
Admiral Charles Richard bereits im Jahr
2022 dazu gesagt hat diese ukraine-krise
in der wir uns gerade befinden ist nur
das Warm Up die große Herausforderung
kommt erst noch und es wird nicht mehr
lange dauern bis er auf eine Art und
Weise getestet werden wie wir es schon
lange nicht mehr erlebt haben als
Befehlshaber des comment es animal
Richard einer der ist wissen muss das
us-dreht komme ist eine übergreifende
Teilstreitkraft im US Militär zuständig
für sämtliche Atomwaffen und die atomare
Abschreckung sowie für die nationale
Raketenabwehr und es befasst sich auch
mit dem Auftrag des Global Strike dabei
handelt es sich um den Anspruch des
US-Militärs innerhalb einer Stunde
überall auf der Welt effektiv zuschlagen
zu können kurzum der diese Truppe
anführt muss genau wissen wie es mit den
Stärken und Schwächen der Teilnehmer im
globalen militärischen Wettbewerb
aussieht und natürlich auch was die
Achillesferse des US Militärs ist der
stärksten Truppe die es je gab
okay aber worauf bezieht sich der
Admiral nun genau nun einerseits ist es
zwar richtig der Krieg in der Ukraine
hat gezeigt wie hoch überlegen westliche
Waffenausbildung und Finanzierung
gegenüber dem Material und Fähigkeiten
der Russen sind doch andererseits hat
dieser test-westlicher Waffen in der
Ukraine auch einige Schwächen ans Licht
gebracht und diese Schwächen geben nun
Anlass zu großer Sorge und um wieder die
Analogie vom Fußball zu bemühen auch der
Weltmeister sollte sich seine eigenen
gewonnen Spiele ansehen denn dabei zeigt
sich oft wo die Abwehr Lücken hat wo
viel Pässe den Gegner nutzen und beim US
Militär sind es genau fünf Schwachpunkte
auf die wir im heutigen Video eingehen
zuvor würde ich euch aber noch gerne
eine frohe Botschaft unseres tollen
Sponsors surfshark überbringen denn ist
ein wirklich empfehlenswertes und
sicheres VPN welches z.B keinerlei
verbindungs- natürlich
vor allem Gefahren schützen die nicht
nach wie vor unsichthalten lassen und
wissen was man tut aber es steht hier
für ein Werkzeug gleich mehreren Vorteil
da zum einen erschwert ist ein
Kombination mit anderen Vorkehrungen
Interaktionen mit nachzuverfolgen und
abzuhören mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
Anonymität im Netz erhöhen zum Beispiel
mit dem integrierten Klima bis alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Popups blocked
weitere Vorteile eines VPN ist dass ihr
so tun könnt als wäre die an einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr zum Beispiel
auf Webseite und Internetdienste
zugreifen im Lande mir gerade nicht
verfügbar werden ob daheim oder im
Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sensur und
gioblocking ein Schnäppchen Netflix und
anderes
anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internetfernsehen im Ausland
gucken mit surfshark kein Problem aber
das ist noch lange nicht alles denn wenn
du einem Surfer konnte wirklich alle
eure Endgeräte EVP registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren Smart TV so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode Politik die
ange bekommt auch noch ein Rabatt in
Höhe von 83% und obendrein die ersten
drei Monate gratis dazu den Link zu
diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nichts besonderes damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanzieren unter die
Arme das könnte übrigens auch direkt mit
Hilfe der Spenden links ebenfalls in die
Videobeschreibung gepackt habe wir sind
euch für jede Unterstützung bei den
damit hätten wir uns euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu
liefern so und nun lasst uns wieder zum
Thema des heutigen Videos zurückkommen
in fünf Schwachpunkten des US-
Frage der Priorität
die Vereinigten Staaten befinden sich an
einem historischen Wendepunkt Putins
Russland läuft quasi Amok nordkorea wird
zu einer immer größeren Bedrohung und
Iran steht kurz davor die Atombombe in
die Hände zu bekommen und dann wäre da
natürlich doch China dass die USA vom
Tabellenplatz Nummer 1 im Supermarkt
Ranking verdrängen will die Zahl der
Herausforderungen war zugegeben schon
immer hoch und sicher ist dass auch der
Grund warum die Vereinigten Staaten die
mit Abstand höchsten Militärhaushalt der
Welt haben die Bedrohungen mit denen wir
heute konfrontiert sind sind gewaltiger
als jemals zuvor in den letzten 20
Jahren trotzdem stellen einigermaßen wie
die der Heritage Foundation fest dass
die Kapazitäten mit den Anforderungen
nicht mithalten können soll heißen die
USA geben zwar viel für emilitär aus
aber sie haben auch viel viel mehr
Verpflichtungen als jedes andere Land
außerdem zahlen die Vereinigten Staaten
den absoluten Zahlen zwar viel für im
Militär im Vergleich zu anderen
Staatsausgaben wird es aber immer
weniger denn wenn wir die Inflation
steigende ausrüstungskosten und Löhne
berücksichtigen ist das Ausgaben Niveau
der letzten Jahre nicht mehr so hoch und
wenn wir die Militärbudgets dann um das
Preisniveau der einzelnen Länder
bereinigen zum Beispiel um den Unterhalt
für ein Soldaten oder die Kosten für
Nachschub ändert sich das Bild ganz
gewaltig
[Musik]
seht euch mal die Daten von 2019 in
dieser Tabelle an die erste Spalte sind
die Militärausgaben der USA die zweite
die ist so mit der Militärausgaben von
China Indien und Russland wie man sieht
sind die Militärausgaben der USA viel
höher aber schaut mal was passiert wenn
wir die Budgets rechnerisch anpassen so
dass Kaufkraftparität herrscht tja dann
passiert folgendes die Supermarkt USA
gibt's zwar immer noch mehr aus als die
anderen aber der Unterschied ist nicht
mehr so groß
ebenso befindet sich der Anteil fürs
Militär im Rahmen der gesamten
Staatsausgaben im freien Fall schaut
euch in dieser Grafik an wie sich der
gesamte Bundeshaushalt in den letzten
Jahren entwickelt hat wie ihr seht gibt
der amerikanische Staat immer mehr Geld
aus hier in der Grafik in Relation zum
Verbraucherpreisindex ein
wahnsinnsanstieg allein Seiter
Jahrtausendwende gemessen an BIP sind
die nicht militärischen Ausgabenseite
Jahrtausendwende sogar fast 50%
gestiegen von 12,6 % des BIP auf 18,6
die Militärausgaben hingegen sind ein
ständig schrumpfender Posten im
Bundeshaushalt setzt euch an
aber das ist noch nicht alles haltet
euch fest denn außerdem sind im
Militärhaushalt neuerdings Milliarden
von Dollar für Dinge die die Begrenzung
der CO2 und anderer Treibhausgasemission
des Militärs enthalten hier zum Beispiel
das Dokument dass ihr hier seht ist der
Umsetzungsplan für die Klimawandel
Strategie der Armee für die Jahre 2023
bis 27 tja ob das die Chinesen irgendwie
beeindruckt wenn die USA mit CO2
neutralen Kampfjets und Panzern
aufwarten vielleicht sollen sich die
Chinesen im Kriegsfall ja totlachen und
die Pfeifen lässt grüßen aber lassen wir
mal den Sarkasmus bei Seite diese
Verschiebung der Prioritäten hat
natürlich Konsequenzen
so wurden die letzten großen
modernisierungspläne der Armee in den
1980er Jahren also vor fast 40 Jahren
durchgeführt aus dieser Zeit stammen
Dinge wieder M1 Abrams Panzer der M2
Bradley oder die Hubschrauber Black Hawk
und ja ich weiß dieses Gerät hat sich in
Folge von vielen Updates immer weiter
verbessert und man ist wohl der
Konkurrenz immer noch weit voraus aber
dennoch wir reden hier über Systeme die
vor fast 40 oder 50 Jahren entworfen
worden sind
[Musik]
also zu einer Zeit als 5 1/4 Zoll
flockig jetzt mit 360 Kilowatt Kapazität
die Spitze der technologischen
Entwicklung darstellten natürlich werdet
ihr jetzt ein wenden das seitdem doch
jede Menge modernes Gerät wie die F35
entwickelt wurde aber nehmt euch in acht
denn wir finden eine sehr ähnliche
Situation auch bei der US Luftwaffe seit
1987 oder die Zahl der Kampfflugzeuge
Bomber Tank und Transportflugzeuge nicht
nur um mehr als 30% reduziert die
Maschine sind heute im Durchschnitt auch
viel viel älter als damals das
Durchschnittsalter der Flugzeugflotte
der USR Force liegt bei
29,4 Jahren
[Musik]
ja so sieht's aus fast 30 Jahre im
Schnitt aller Flugzeuge und das heißt es
gibt da noch so einige Ausreißer nach
oben einige Flugzeugtypen wieder B25
Bomber und die KC 135 Tank Flugzeuge
bringen es auf über 60 Jahre das
Durchschnittsalter der f15c liegt bei
rund 38 Jahren und dass der f16c und
D-Version war über 31 Jahren und ja ich
weiß dass ich die meisten von ihnen auf
dem neuesten Stand befinden stets gehabt
und gut gewartet gut gebaute und
gewartete Flugzeuge können tatsächlich
jahrzehntelang ihren Dienst verrichten
aber es ist und bleibt Gerede das bei
seiner Entwicklung oft gar nicht für
solche eine lange Dienstzeit und für die
heutigen Szenarien vorgesehen war und
ehrlich gesagt dr hat man seitens der
Air Force auch an so manchen
Verschleißerscheinungen herum so machte
die f15c immer mal wieder Probleme denn
das Anfang Jäger sind diese Fliege
enormen die Kräften ausgesetzt was
natürlich das Material ermüdet die jetzt
wussten zeitweise am Boden bleiben aus
Sicherheitsgründen das Ausbessern kostet
natürlich Geld und es kostet immer noch
weil man die Wartungsintervalle
verkürzen wissen musste viele analysten
befürchten daher das mit den
Streitkräften das gleiche passieren wird
was bereits mit der Infrastruktur der
USA geschehen ist der Abstieg in einen
Zustand des Städten Verfalls statt einen
der Modernisierung es reicht eben nicht
aus einmal ordentlich in den Geldbeutel
zu langen um eine riesige Infrastruktur
oder Militärmaschine aufzubauen nein je
größer und komplexer diese gigantischen
Systeme sind desto schwieriger und
teurer ist ihre Instandhaltung und
regelmäßige Erneuerung ohne dies
einzuplanen ist die beste Investition
irgendwann nichts mehr wert im Gegenteil
sie wird zu einer riesen Belastung das
heißt wenn die Politiker in Washington
andere Prioritäten beim Budget setzen
werden die militärischen Systeme
allmählich in einem alarmierenden Ausmaß
altern und nutzlos und aus diesem Grund
wird befürchtet dass die ständig
steigenden Sozialausgaben alles andere
verschlingen werden überrascht nun wir
fangen gerade erst an das zweite große
Problem ist durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine in den Fokus gerückt um was es
geht nun hört gut zu
viel Bürokratie zu wenig Munition
das US-Militär ist zwar seit Jahrzehnten
das mächtigste der Welt vor allem aus
deutscher Sicht mit der Tod gesparten
Bundeswehr wirkt das us-arsenal wie ein
militärisches Schlaraffenland der
Ukraine Krieg hat jedoch eine Schwäche
der Amerikaner offenbart der Mangel an
Munition und Nachschub eine große Krieg
ist und bleibt in erster Linie ein
industrieller Krieg das heißt dass eine
Armee nicht nur über die besten Waffen
verfügen muss sondern auch über eine
gesicherte Versorgung zu der
logischerweise auch Munition gehört
so haben die USA schätzungsweise ein
Drittel ihrer gesamten Bestände ein
Javel in Panzerabwehrraketen uns in der
Flugabwehrraketen in die Ukraine
geliefert und leider kann man die nicht
einfach so mal schnell nachproduzieren
und ein paar Wochen ist alles wieder in
Ordnung nein bei den derzeitigen
Produktionsraten würde es mehr als 7
Jahre dauern bis die Ukraine gelieferten
Bestände wieder aufgefüllt sind im Falle
das Dinger sind es sogar mehr als 13
Jahre wenn man die frühere
Produktionskapazität zu Grunde liegt
aber wie um alles in der Welt ist das
überhaupt möglich
[Musik]
nun wie gesagt wir haben schon in einem
früheren Video darüber gesprochen man
hat die Lieferketten total
vernachlässigt statt diese effizienter
zu machen und dann mindestens in guten
Zustand zu halten lag die Priorität
darin neues Kriegsgerät zu kaufen und zu
entwickeln das heißt neue Flugzeuge neue
Flugzeugträger und neue gepanzertes
Fahrzeuge aber haben wir vorhin nicht
erzählt dass die Flieger und die Panzer
alt sind ja das stimmt was wir hier mit
neuen Projekten sind Prestige Objekte in
relativ geringen Stückzahlen okay aber
was hatte das nun für Auswirkungen auf
die Produktion der bisherigen
bestandswaffen nur die
Produktionskapazitäten der
althergebrachten Systeme zurück die
waren halt nicht mehr so gefragt simple
Munition ist halt nicht so sexy wie ein
neuer F35 Jet oder ein riesiger
Flugzeugträger wir geben eine Menge Geld
für eine sehr exquisite großes Thema aus
und konzentrieren uns nicht so sehr auf
die Munition diese Unterstützung dieser
Systeme notwendig ist der Punkt ist
natürlich das seit Ende des ersten
kalten Krieges der munitionsbedarf der
USA mehr auch nicht mehr so riesig war
erinnert ihr euch noch an die Kriege im
Irak oder in Afghanistan die
Überlegenheit der Amerikaner war ein
militärisch so hoch dass man keine
großen und lang andauernden Einsätze
führen musste wenn wir jedoch an China
und einen potenziellen Konflikt und
Taiwan denken Sie die Sache ganz anders
aus unter diesen Umständen könnte der
Bedarf eine Munition die derzeitigen
Bestände und Produktionskapazitäten bei
weitem übersteigen
[Musik]
laut einer Reihe von Analysen und
kriegssenarios die vom Center Force red
DJ und international studies einer
führenden US Denkfabrik entwickelt
wurden könnte den USA im Falle eines
Zusammenstoßes mit China ein weniger als
einer Woche die langstreckenmunition und
die präzisionsgelenken Waffen ausgehen
und das ist genau das Problem dass
hinter Schlagzeilen wie diesen steckt
die USA die will raketenproduktion
drastisch erhöhen das Problem ist dass
es lange dauert diese Menge abzustellen
es erfordert qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte
Investitionen in neue Fabriken ohne die
Erweiterung Bestehen der
Produktionsanlagen außerdem den Aufbau
von Logistik Netzwerken und
Zulieferketten und so weiter und so fort
erinnert ihr euch noch an den Fall das
Dinger Rakete der Geschäftsführer von
den Hersteller des System sagte dass die
volle wieder Aufnahme der Produktion
dieses Gerät nicht weniger als 18 Monate
dauern würde noch schlimmer ist das
nicht nur die Vereinigten Staaten von
diesem Mangel betroffen sind die meisten
ihre Verbündeten befinden sich in einer
ähnlichen Situation und vervielfachen
damit das Problem für die westliche Welt
die er quasi mit den USA in einem Boot
sitzt werfen wir mal einen Blick auf den
Bedarf der Ukraine
nach Meinung viele Analysten könnte und
sollte dieses Land mindestens 250.000
Artilleriegranaten pro Monat abfeuern
aber tatsächlich wird weniger als die
Hälfte davon verschossen und warum nun
weil die 12 europäischen Unternehmen die
die nötige Munition dafür herstellen
kaum die Kapazität haben 650.000
Geschosse in einem ganzen Jahr zu
produzieren und in den Vereinigten
Staaten liegt die Produktion bei etwa
20.000 geschossen pro Monat
aber das ist noch nicht alles es ist
auch sehr schwierig einige grundlegende
Komponenten zu finden die in den USA und
nicht in den Ländern wie hier
hergestellt werden diese mittlerweile
als klares Risiko für die nationale
Sicherheit angesehen im September 2022
wurden z.B alle Auslieferungen neuer F35
für eine gewisse Zeit gestoppt denn
einige Bauteile benötigten eine in China
hergestellte Legierung okay aber
immerhin tut sich etwas beim Budget zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt hat die Regierung
beiden in ihrem Haushaltsantrag an den
Kongress eine Auswirkungen der Mittel
für den Kauf von Raketen und Munition
und mehr als 50 % vorgesehen das soll
nicht nur die an die Ukraine gelieferten
Bestände auffüllen sein auch die
Lieferketten wieder aktivieren auf diese
Weise soll zum Beispiel die Produktion
von Natalie Granaten nur zwei Jahren um
500% gesteigert
werdendings in working
time lights
tja aber leider sind Lieferketten und
Nachschub nicht das Ende der Probleme
seht her der Beschaffungsprozess des
Pentagons ist zu langsam um China zu
schlagen auf der Überholspur China
bekommt schneller neue Waffen als die
USA man mag es kaum glauben aber die
Zeit die das Pentagon braucht um einen
Bedarf zu ermitteln und einen Auftrag zu
vergeben hat sich seit dem 1950er Jahren
Vers 7 Fach der Prozess ist zu langsam
und zu umständlich
gewordene Bürokratie die man in
Deutschland z.B auch nur zu gut kennt
aber darüber haben wir ein eigenes Video
gedreht und ich werde es Euch auch
verlinken und wie gesagt aber nicht
vergessen und die Probleme mit der
Beschaffung des militärischen Geräts
bringen uns direkt zum dritten großen
Problem der US-Streitkräfte denn auch
bei den Waffenschmieden in Amerika gibt
es ein Problem genauer gesagt handelt es
sich um ein ökonomisches Phänomen das
hier negative Folgen hat was genau wird
damit meint nun hört jetzt gut
[Musik]
die Macht der Giganten
seit dem Zusammenbruch des so wird Union
lässt die Zahl der Hauptauftragnehmer
also der hauptzuliefer des US-Militärs
von mehr als 80 auf 5 gesunken diese Big
Five seht ihr hier auf dem Bildschirm
vor nicht allzu vielen Jahren hatten wir
fünfmal so viele Auftragnehmer und es
gab mehr Wettbewerb und mehr Kreativität
mit anderen Worten der militärisch
industrielle Komplex vor dem 1961
Präsident Eisenhauer warte wird heute
von einer Handvoll Giganten kontrolliert
praktisch alles läuft über sie ein
Beispiel während das
Verteidigungsministerium vor 30 Jahren
auf acht Lieferanten von
Militärflugzeugen zählen konnte sind es
heute nur noch drei Boeing Logitech
Marketing und northop grande bei den
Raketen ist die Zahl von acht auf drei
gesunken 90% der US Raketen werden heute
von nur drei Unternehmen hergestellt
Boeing Logitech Martin und Racing und
bei bestimmten Bauteilen für Waffen ist
die Situation sogar noch schlimmer
die javeland Panzerabwehr geht es zum
Beispiel basiert auf dem
fortschrittlichen feststofftriebwerk der
Firma arrojet Rocket dyn und zu diesem
Hersteller gibt es keine Alternative
niemanden der ebenfalls solche
speziellen Triebwerke bauen könnte wenn
dieses Unternehmen ein Problem haben
sollte einen Produktionsausfall einen
Unfall oder was auch immer dann fällt
praktisch der Nachschub für ein ganzes
Waffensystem aus für ein ziemlich
kritisches Waffensystem ein anderes
Unternehmen Williams international baut
die Turbo vertriebwerke für die meisten
Marschflugkörper der Amis und auch hier
finden wir dasselbe vor wenn dieser
Zulieferer Probleme hat fehlt der
Nachschub für das gesamte Waffensystem
es gibt wirklich 0 Redundanz und
Sicherheitspuffer
aber die Reduzierung auf so wenig
Unternehmen verringert auch den
Wettbewerb der waffenschmieten
untereinander und ihr wisst sicher was
das bedeutet weniger Innovation mehr
Kosten für den Kunden weniger freie
Produktionskapazitäten weniger
Arbeitsplätze und insgesamt viel mehr
Abhängigkeit von diesen wenigen
Unternehmen nach an Rahmen der
US-Regierung selbst generieren kleine
Unternehmen fast 17 mal mehr Patente als
große Konzerne doch in den letzten zehn
Jahren ist die Zahl der kleinen
Unternehmen im militärisch industriellen
Komplex der USA um 40 Prozent gesunken
klar es handelt sich um einen
Konzentrationsprozess denn der
Wirtschaft oft vorkommt aber eben zu
Lasten des Wettbewerbs und damit zum
Nachteil des Kunden hier des US-Militärs
und schlimmer noch in diesem Fall es
gefährdet ja auch noch die Sicherheit
des ganzen Landes und praktisch auch der
gesamten westlichen Welt tja so weit so
schlecht aber als ob das noch nicht
genug wäre kommen wir jetzt zum vierten
großen Problem mit dem die
US-Streitkräfte heute konfrontiert sind
Soldaten Soldaten und nochmals Soldaten
ganz genau Soldaten es herrscht ganz
einfach eine Mangel an Leuten die ihren
Dienst in der arme tun die Vereinigten
Staaten erleben gerade die schlechteste
rekrutierungsphase seit 19
73 die Zahlen zeigen dass 2022 ein
schlechtes Jahr war und 2023 wird wohl
noch schlechter werden so hat das her im
Haushaltsjahr 2022 sein
rekrutierungsziel um 15.000 Soldaten
verfehlt und im Jahr 2023 könnte diese
Zahl um 20.000 niedriger sein wenn man
also auch noch jede Mercedes die aus dem
Dienst ausscheiden wird erwartet dass
die US Army aus dem Haushaltsjahr 2023
mit etwa 450.000 Soldaten herausgehen
das Problem dabei um allen militärischen
Anforderungen gerecht zu werden hält man
mehr als 500.000 Soldaten im Herd für
notwendig und auch der Rest der
Streitkräfte befindet sich in einer sehr
ähnlichen Situation die Militärakademie
melden krasse Rückgänge so sind zum
Beispiel die Bewerbungen an der Air
Force Academy um 28 % zurückgegangen die
an der Nebel Academy um 20 und in
Westpoint um 10 %. das erklärt
Nachrichten wie diese nee die storniert
vorzeitige Entlassungen und bietet
Verlängerungen an um mehr Matrosen im
Dienst zu halten aber warum wollen nur
noch so wenige Leute zum Militär man
kann dort schließlich gutes Geld
verdienen ohne also wirkliche Risiko
eingehen zu müssen plötzlich in einem
Krieg kämpfen zu müssen nun ja in den
USA brummt zur Zeit der Jobmotor in der
freien Wirtschaft die Arbeitslosenquote
ist auf eine historischen Tiefstand und
da wirkt nun mal das Militär nicht mehr
so attraktiv potenzieller Kriegseinsatz
auf der einen oder das warme Homeoffice
auf der anderen Seite da fällt die
Entscheidung vielen sehr sehr leicht
aber das ist nicht das einzige Problem
[Musik]
immer mehr Amerikanern fehlen auch die
physischen Voraussetzungen für den
Dienst in der Truppe sie Probleme Asthma
psychische Probleme und nicht zuletzt
Fettleibigkeit und nein an dieser Stelle
kommt jetzt keine Werbung für ein
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel keine Angst
aber passen würde er schon der Anteil
der Soldaten die völlig ohne
Einschränkungen in ihrem
dienstverrechnen Können ist seit 2016
und 29 % auf
23%. so erschweren kommt in so dass die
Streitkräfte auch in Sachen Beliebtheit
schon bessere Tage gesehen haben das mag
verschiedene Gründe haben auf die wir
hier nicht alle eingehen können wichtig
ist für uns der Fakt das ist offenbar so
ist einige Umfragen zeigen dass das
Vertrauen ist militären in den letzten
Jahren deutlich gesunken ist
Umfrage Vertrauen in das US-Militär
bleibt unter 50% etwa 48 % der
Amerikaner sagen dass sie großes
Vertrauen in das Militär haben ein
leichter Anstieg gegenüber 45% im
letzten Jahr das Vertrauen in das US
Militär ist in den vergangenen Jahren
stark gesunken im Jahr 2018 sagten doch
etwa 70% Amerikaner dass sie großes
Vertrauen in diese Institution hätten
und schließlich hätten wir noch das
fünfte Problem und das ist ein ziemlich
großer Brocken aufgepasst
[Musik]
neue Anforderungen und neue Bedrohungen
versteht mich nicht falsch trotz all der
Probleme die wir gesehen haben ist das
US-Militär im Vergleich zur weltweiten
Konkurrenz noch immer auf einem ganz
anderen Level doch genau diese
Konkurrenz lässt dem Spitzenreiter keine
ruhige Minute das US Militär ist quasi
Dauer beschäftigt und das laugt aus okay
was bei mir damit konkret 0 China
modernisiert sein Militär in vollem
Tempo und verfolgt eine zunehmende
aggressive Außenpolitik Russland ist
gerade zu einem völlig unberechtbaren
Gegner geworden nicht nur weil es
Eroberungskriege als legitim ansieht
nein Putin hat z.B auch das new Startup
Abkommen ausgesetzt dass darauf abzielte
die Gesamtzahl der stationierten
atomköpfe zu begrenzen und was ist mit
den Verbündeten nun auch die machen
Arbeit und zwar indem sie Hilfe brauchen
was wäre wohl los in Europa ohne das
us-schaltkräfte vor Ort sind es kostet
viel Geld Material Ressourcen um in
Europa jene sicherheitspolitischen
Aufgaben zu übernehmen die die
Verbündeten eigentlich alleine stemmen
müssen die USA sind hier in einer Lage
wie ein Stürmer beim Fußball der auch
noch in der Abwehrkette aus helfen muss
aber zurück zu den Feinden und Gegnern
in der Welt da wird Nordkorea zu einer
wachsenden nuklearen Bedrohung und auch
der Iran scheint kurz davor zu stehen
die Atombombe in die Hände zu bekommen
noscom die USA werden 2.35 eine erhöhtes
Risiko gegen nordkoreanische
Interkontinentalraketen eingehen
das alles wird unter anderem dazu führen
dass das Raketenabwehrsystem weiter
ausgebaut werden muss denn die neuen
Fähigkeiten dieser Staaten bedrohen
mittlerweile nicht mehr nur die
Verbündeten sondern auch bereits Teil
des us-territoriums Selbst und da hatte
man seitens der USA früher schon einmal
ganz andere Ambitionen in Sachen
Verteidigung in den 1980er Jahren
kündigte die damalige Regen Regierung
mit der strategischen
verteidigungsinitiative ist die an
hunderte abwerteten gegen anliegende
interkontinental Raketen zu stationieren
heute hingegen stehen für diesen Zweck
nur und 40 Boden gestützte Raketen zur
Verfügung und hier ein effektives und
effizientes System aufzubauen braucht es
natürlich viel Geld und viel Energie und
das ist nur ein Beispiel
ihr habt also gesehen so stark dass US
Militär auch ist es ist nicht frei von
Problemen und kann sich nicht auf seinem
Spitzenplatz ausholen es rot angesichts
der derzeitigen Weltlage sogar eine
gewisse Überforderung natürlich ist das
amerikanische Arsenal gewaltig B1 und B2
Bomber die macht sich F 22 Chats die F35
der Apache Hubschrauber die U-Boote der
Ohio und Virginia Klasse die Tomahawk
Raketen die Flugzeugträger Niemetz und
fortklasse die Abbruchs Panzer die mir
als 400 heimeres Raketenwerfer und die
fast 1000 Werfer des Typs m270 tja und
diese Liste könnten wir doch lange
fortführen wer solche Waffen besitzt ist
derzeit vielleicht unbesiegbar aber ihr
seht das ist immer Raum für
Verbesserungen gibt und wie wir anfangs
gesagt haben an der Spitze zu bleiben
ist eine ganz eigene und extreme
schwierige Disziplin aber an dieser
Stelle interessiert uns was ihr darüber
denkt glaubt ihr dass die USA ihre
globale militärische Vorherrschaft in
den nächsten Jahrzehnten aufrecht
erhalten werden welche Schwächen im US
Militär oder den Armenien des Westen
sieht ihr würdet ihr zu Militär gehen
und wenn nein warum nicht wie immer sind
wir auf eure Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt
uns bitte einen like und teils mit euren
Freunden um es mit ihnen zu diskutieren
natürlich freuen uns auch wie gesagt
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiter zuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]